siamo ritornati su scrive il frutto io
ho visto che la scorsa settimana è stato
abbastanza delirante perché non
peggiorare questa ragazzi sono con la
mia clip sono nichi luca leo pietro
tutto tutti stanchi spero che vi piaccia
buona visione le dico perché no non mi
sta scrivendo che è impossibile ma cos'è
la montagna è facilissimo ma ok perché
non mi veniva ma che bruttissimo ma un
festa rega uno dei disegni più belli che
vedrete passato allora come come
appaiono in die hard e nestor ex
miliardo più bello di così non si poteva
ma c'è qualcosa che ti fa dire vediamo
un po non si capisce ma colui ragazze
[Musica]
indicate 86 quando il cazzone che sta
disegnando anche se ma poi cosa mi
rappresenta quella riga ma da aidaa ma
ho capito che cosa era quella c scuse
cosa rappresenta niente è la i e la cia
e anabio lete difficile dai stupisce
allora che cos'è la vacca che cazzo
tacco 13 13 iscritti a scrivere quindi
scuole parco giochi
ma se la dulko 13 parco giochi che è
frutto incredibile
ora è facile pd è capito
106 che cacchio è mito delle api sì
siamo in un altro modo
cara gara fi horror a nido d'api si
chiama si parla delle la stalla delle
armi e una file ma questa è una c 130
con il pezzo è confuso sarà di questo
inizia con la ha però è veramente bello
con gli occhi vi hanno ancora di più
ma cos'è questo ma com'è possibile un
albero a prezzi per tutti casa demoni a
te la devi fare quella cosa che ci è
vero un impiccato sull'altro l'ho fatto
ok serve serve serve proprio la seconda
parola che cazzo di 61 buster anche dal
buster ma forniva donadoni c'è proprio
madonne si è l'unica cosa che insieme
hai fatto grande ma portato quagliato
scritto da cani
l'italia è veramente ori ci sto facendo
che schifo guardate io né califone
questa macrì inglese è in inglese e la
unghia del piede ma ci è mancato
perché presagio attenzione allora
oddio la faccia di un uomo gli ha detto
è palesemente una buona occasione
[Risate]
mamma mia ma di rimetterlo dopo il ragno
però quasi ma che cos'era
ma secondo marroni con hadji gun si
fanno così le macchine vero forse forse
quelle col naso di cars è una bottiglia
sulle ruote è un cannone vision fisse
quasi quella mamma mia
ok cielo cos'è la bella non solo della
rampa però non l'ha detto là dentro non
ho capito
vabbè magari curate l'unico colore che
non ho mai visto su una macchina tra ma
perché trasparente infatti se con le
ruote peppino era per depistare ma
adesso deve avere mister bean dall'altra
quale era difficilissimo ma cosa di
sbagliato
bellissima e se fosse permesso e niente
un disegno più bello di questo
pomeriggio infatti mi viene come si
chiama chiude il dialogo era giusta
libero possa possibilità mof
ma dai ma chi l'ha mai chiamati in quel
modo io mai personalmente dell'ultima e
mosca cercando su google perché non mi
dichiarava molecole
eppure triste de canio ci sia qualcosa
qualcosa come mi ricordo come si chiama
facciamo anche se agiti una bottiglia
alle scarci allora mi ha detto mamma mia
è vero vince ancora
questo è facile cosa ma cosa hai la dei
sen so cos'altro fare per creare esimo
la fine porca vacca
no no no no previsto a nicastro e modo
masilla no come è facile per noi non è
possibile
meno convinti si non sono titolari era
fatta io arrivai mai amato lunga la
distanza
allora ma come fanno indovinarla ma non
è vero c'è non ci credo consigli dai
chip non è possibile
ok
adesso seguito di nuovo la linea ma
cos'è
hai visto mai dal basso io non sono
affatto indovinarla lieve questi cosi ma
era tutto prevedibile sino alla fine e
non è lui aveva vinto lo stesso
spero che vi sia piaciuto scegliamo il
prossimo bisogna sapere che ti scrivo il
punto io fra che mi sta a me comunque i
ragazzi mi piace un sacco registrare
quindi ci vediamo al proseguito site.it
scheda canale speciale tasto mi piace e
noi come sempre ci via
[Musica]